I'm Jen briny and I'm the host of the
Congressional dish podcast and I'm here
in Boston a filling in for David while
he's in the sky traveling to Las Vegas
where he's going to be reporting for you
for the rest of the week but while he's
in transit I'm here today to tell you
about one of the most important laws
that's been created since this Congress
and the Trump administration began a law
that I feel hasn't gotten nearly enough
coverage in the mainstream press belong
talking about is the Omnibus government
funding law that was signed by Trump on
march ör President Trump on March 23rd
this law funded all of the operations of
the federal government for 2018 and they
only completed it six months late the
way this law was created is a
straight-up scandal or at least I think
it should be and so today I want to tell
you the story of how that happened
and about a few things that hitchhiked
their way into law as attachments to
this must sign piece of legislation but
before I start this story let's do a
little refresher on our Schoolhouse Rock
I know that the audience members of the
David Pakman show are very knowledgeable
but sometimes we just need to be
reminded about how a bill becomes a law
because the way this is this has to work
really is that a bill needs to pass the
House of Representatives and the Senate
in identical form and then be signed by
the president the part of the government
that Congress needs to fund every year
the part that governs most of the
day-to-day operations is divided into
twelve categories and so there's
supposed to be 12 different funding laws
one per section that are signed into law
by September 30th the end of the fiscal
year every year now there are 12
committees these are called
appropriations committees appropriations
is a fancy word for funding but there
are these twelve committees in the House
of Representatives that are responsible
for creating the twelve different
funding bills now for 2018 that actually
happened in the House of Representatives
the twelve bills not only pass their
committees but they also all passed the
House of Representatives
however the Republicans attached so many
non-essential ideological measures to
those bills but they were basically dead
on arrival in the Senate where some
Democratic votes are
needed because the Republicans don't
have a veto-proof majority and so when
the deadline came last year to fund the
government for this year on September
30th Congress had completed exactly zero
of the 12 funding laws which led to a
parade of continuing resolutions now
continuing resolutions are funding laws
that are simply and thoughtlessly
extending the funding levels from the
previous year and when federal agencies
have to operate under a continuing
resolution they're not able to start any
new projects or do any long-term
planning and so the agencies hate them
115 Congress over the past six months
funded the government with a continuing
resolution five times which is not
normal
now when it became clear that Congress
wasn't going to meet their September
30th deadline that's when we got the
first continuing resolution and that was
valid until December 8th then on
December 8th we got our second
continuing resolution or CR as the cool
kids call it this time it was just for a
few weeks so until December 22nd then on
December 22nd preventing a government
shutdown over Christmas we got our third
CR and I just want to pause for a moment
because that's a really important aspect
of these CRS because they are government
funding laws the consequences of them
not being signed is a government
shutdown which makes them must sign
legislation and because these are must
sign pieces of legislation members of
Congress attach all kinds of things to
these laws so that their pet policies
can hitchhike away into law to these
extra provisions oftentimes have no
debate and more frequently than you
might think
without the majority of people in
Congress even knowing that they're there
for example in the December 22nd CR four
billion dollars in so-called emergency
spending was attached for missile
defense a month later when that CR
expired on January 22nd and after a
weekend-long government shutdown CR
number 4 allowed that 4 billion dollars
which was originally for missile defense
to be transferred to any of the
intelligence agencies of which we have
16 for activities that haven't been
authorized by Congress yet and they
could do so
out notifying Congress and that
disturbing provision hitchhike its way
into law despite the fact that the
Republican chairman of the Senate
Intelligence Committee Senator Richard
Burr and the Democratic vice chairman
Senator Mark Warner both went to the
Senate floor to tell the other senators
that this was slipped in and they tried
unsuccessfully to get it removed from
the bill as a result this language could
erode the powers of the authorizing
committee effectively the intelligence
community could expend funds as it sees
fit without authorization bill in place
and with no statutory direction
indicating that an authorization bill
for 2018 is forthcoming
if this exemption is granted you could
potentially have an administration any
administration go off and take on covert
action activities for example with no
ability for our committee which spends
the time and has the oversight to say
timeout or to say we actually disagree
with that policy despite that bipartisan
warning from the two men most in the
know because the government shutdown
would have been extended if they made
any changes that provision giving a four
billion dollar blank check to the
intelligence agencies hitchhiked in the
law then a few weeks later we got CR
number five which ended the second
government shutdown of the hundred
fifteen Congress which began and ended
in one night while most of it most of us
were sleeping but in that CR in addition
to doing all sorts of things like
suspending the debt ceiling for a year
and forcing the sale of hundreds of
millions of barrels of oil from our
emergency stockpile well in addition to
that it also set budget caps for both
2018 and 2019 which is why when the
government was finally funded for 2018
halfway through the fiscal year on March
23rd it was able to blast through the
previous budget caps and spend 1.3
trillion dollars far more than last year
but I'm not going to focus on the
spending for this story because I want
you to understand how this bill became
law because the text of the bill was
released at 8:00 p.m. on Wednesday March
21st
the text was 2232 pages long and the
reason it was that long is that they
funded the government by taking all 12
sections of government that were
supposed to be separate bills and they
funded them with one monster of a law
known as an omnibus keeping in mind that
the omnibus was law by lunchtime on
March 23rd it's the problem that the
2232 page text of the omnibus wasn't
given to the math vast majority of the
members of Congress or the public whose
money is being spent until 8 p.m. on
March 21st less than 48 hours before it
became law and this is the situation our
members of Congress found themselves in
this is representative Jim McGovern of
Western Massachusetts in the rules
committee hearing this is the only
hearing that took place about this bill
he's speaking out about 11:00 p.m. on
that Wednesday March 21st about 3 hours
after the 2200 32 pages of text was
released and two hours before it passed
the committee I'm gonna tell you in
advance I'm probably not gonna have very
many questions because I don't know what
to ask I know that there were some
things here that I would like and some
things I don't like what I'm worried
about is the stuff I don't know this
this is 2200 pages that we just received
even if I went to the Evelyn wood speed
being school I couldn't get through this
in time for the vote and I just I point
out and this is not your fault
because you have no control over this
but this process leaves a lot to be
desired and I you know I I the life of
me I don't know why we go from one
crisis to another crisis to another
crisis I mean the urgency now is that if
we don't do something quickly we're
going to shut the government down again
and I it's got to be a better way to do
this and one in which people actually
know what they're voting on and so
despite the fact that it was literally
impossible for anyone in Congress to
read it the Omnibus passed the committee
at about 1:00 a.m. and then 12 hours
later by 1:00 p.m. on March 22nd it
passed the House of Representatives 256
to 167 the vote wasn't even close and
then the omnibus went to the Senate
where it didn't pass until 12 21 a.m.
which
was longer than most of the senators
expected it to take and there was a
senator who complained publicly on the
Senate floor to Mitch McConnell's face
about the bill being passed at 12:20
a.m. but not because he didn't have a
chance to read it
oh no senator bob Corker of tennessee
was irritated because he was awoken from
his beauty sleep for the vote here's
what he said I had called down earlier
and asked the secretary if we're not
going to vote by 10 o'clock
if we could just vote at 8 o'clock in
the morning I mean this is ridiculous
it's juvenile this is a juvenile process
that we go through every time we do one
of these I would respectfully ask our
leader who's been dealing with a lot
today and I'm glad that he has the job
that he has and I don't and the
Secretary has the job that she has and I
don't but could you explain to us what
has occurred over the last 11 hours that
keeps us here voting on a bill that we
all know it's going to pass regardless
of how we vote on it that has kept us
from just going ahead and voting it
could you explain to the body just very
quickly what has happened and could we
in the future possibly try to resolve
these things at a decent hour or come
back the next morning and vote he was
sleepy that was his problem with this
process but it turns out that we did
find out the reason why the vote on the
Encyclopaedia sides bill that no one
read took a whole half a day to pass the
Senate and hat tip to Mike de baños in
the Washington Post for telling us this
story but it turned out that it got
stalled all day by Senator James rich of
Idaho because he wanted a provision
removed now remember the bill had to
pass the House and the Senate in
identical form and so amending the bill
in any way would have required the house
to vote again and many members of the
House of Representatives have already
bounced for their two-week vacation by
the time the Senate was voting and so
his request was a big one it would have
likely led to a third government
shutdown of the hundred and fifteen
Congress and Senator rich knew it and so
what provision was so important that
James rish threw a hissy fit to get it
removed well the provision he was
against was one that renamed the white
clouds wilderness in central Idaho after
Idaho's former governor Cecil D Andrus
who died last year
apparently Senator Risch and former
governor Andrus hated each other and so
this vindictive senator was willing to
shut down the federal government to
prevent the former Democratic governor
from being honored even in his death he
also did this despite all of the things
in this bill that could actually have
been objected to for Policy reasons and
here's the thing about Senator James
rich cuz he's not really one of the
famous ones I didn't really know
anything about him before hearing this
story but if we allow the Republicans to
keep the Senate in November you probably
will hear about him much more because
this is the senator who would be most
likely to become the new chairman of the
powerful Senate Foreign Relations
Committee which is overseeing all our
war things after senator bob Corker of
tennessee retires Oh
Oh anyway the next day was the deadline
day the day that this thing had to be
signed and it was also the day of the
funeral for her representative Louise
slaughter of New York and it was just it
was kind of crazy to me that this was
the day that this was going to be signed
into law because Louise slaughter was
one of only four Democrats that sat on
the House Rules Committee so she would
have been in the only hearing about this
omnibus and she would have been furious
and for all the right reasons but anyway
you know while her funeral was taking
place the bill had passed the house and
it had passed the Senate in identical
form and all it needed was Trump's
signature and of course literally five
minutes before Louise slaughter funeral
we got a Trump tweet he said quote I am
considering a veto in all caps of the
omnibus spending bill based on the fact
that the 800,000 Plus daca recipients
have been totally abandoned by the
Democrats not even mentioned in bill and
the border wall all caps which is
desperately needed for our national
defense is not fully funded and then he
signed it four hours later and so that's
how the Republican Party is funding the
operations of our government
and as their employers how does this
story make you feel about their job
performance please make sure to call and
tell David at two one nine two david p
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership